hey guys it's jasmine i love food i love
that food connects us i love that it
brings us together made me start
thinking
do you think we can use food to
communicate with ghosts so today we are
going to a haunted restaurant and it's
also a historical hollywood hot spot and
we're going to try and cook for a couple
of ghosts what do you guys think about
that i'm a little skeptical that we're
actually going to see anything i'm
scared you guys ready yeah
i think so you guys believe in ghosts
right i i get scared of ghost movies but
i've never seen a ghost so i guess part
of me must believe well
one avid believer
i'm skeptical that anything's gonna
happen i believe there's a possibility
i'm terrified i hope we don't see
anything or hear anything fair warning i
i did
bring us on this crazy adventure but
if something happens i
may bail first we're going to talk to a
couple of employees the historian and a
couple of others who have had spooky
experiences and then we're going to the
kitchen to try and communicate with the
former owner lemkuan and then the former
bartender lindsay so those are two like
known
ghosts potentially there there's
actually more
we're here okay
all right let's go
my name is maxim chopavolov i'm a
historian and archivist for formosa cafe
formosa cafe is a bar in restaurant in
west hollywood which first was opened in
1939. carmosa was always famous for four
things it's a place where you can have a
decent meal steve drink cash a check or
make a bet formosa was visited by many
celebrities frank sinatra elvis presley
marilyn monroe john wayne all those big
names they all been here
they've been here all
somebody's trained together
no no they're gone no one was there yeah
they got sure dude no one they are girls
someone just tried to get through the
door
and no one was there well lindy
brewerton is the gentleman who was who
spent 40 years behind the bar could he
be a ghost
i would think so i i don't have any
ghost stories
but many people have when lam quan was a
chef in the restaurant he uh his
specialty was serfendorf he would serve
steak and the lobster and of course
chinese food seems like the most popular
was wonton
soup
many people made comments that you know
i love hermosa i love food atmosphere
but one town was like the one
if you want to make a connection with
lam kwon tonight or any ghosts in this
place why don't you start with wonton
soup i wish you luck i feel like you're
sending us
to the ghosts the formosa cafe is 100
haunted and i'll tell you why this is
the main bar the main bar has been here
since 1939 prior to that it has been
here since the 20s as a as a cafe it was
the kind of place that people
felt at home and they also party they
had fun here and i think a lot of the
spirits
congregated back here because that's
where their friends were and that's
where they had fun the lights go off
randomly right now this light is off
it it'll be a different light uh
every day it'll be a different light
this light will probably come back on in
an hour this booth is notoriously
haunted it was bugsy siegel's booth and
he had a floor safe installed and i've
got another spot i want to show you in
the back of the train so in the main bar
is where i feel things uh but in the
train cars where i actually see things i
see silhouettes of people in the back of
the train car behind the curtains now
this is the oldest red car train in
existence it probably brought the ghosts
of travelers along with it when it was
put here and then it's filled with
ghosts you know until today this is
lem's booth he would sit here because he
could keep an eye on the front door and
he could keep an eye on the kitchen you
should talk with sonny she's the one
who's had the most experience with lem
and this booth i'm sunny i'm a bartender
here at formosa and it's true this place
is haunted run us through your
experiences the craziest thing that
happened to me was i was standing here
one night i had patrons right here at
the bar and i turned around and i
reached for this
stack of glasses we had not touched it
all night it hadn't been washed there's
no temperature difference and i barely
touch it with my fingertips right here
and the whole glass explodes
and it went right down here on the
ground like down into the left
and there was no glass anywhere in the
well
in my hair and my clothes i was not cut
other nights i have been hanging out on
the little in the rickshaw and the patio
right out there
the other bartender who was here came
running outside and she was like where
did that person go i just saw a guy walk
through the bar area and i was like
nobody's here okay i'm just kidding like
i'm getting chills right now do you
react well to these like you seem so
like bubbly uh i kind of just play it
like that i don't think it's malicious
it's just kind of like hey we're
reminding you
whose place this really is they are
friendly maybe they'll talk to you today
while you're cooking good luck so
something just happened when we were in
the kitchen setting up for cooking
you can
come with me
so basically mimo
is helping us she's our culinary
producer uh and she was helping us prep
and it was just sitting
over in the kitchen by itself all of the
like the peanut oil and the sesame oil
was all spilled
we have a ghost hunting
towards the area where this tray was
laying and straight up a silhouette of a
man standing on the counter so the tray
was i put it right here
next to like all these things yeah and
then i come back and it's all spilled
and it's like glass and it's not broken
it doesn't make any sense like how does
oil spill from that
so i've never made wonton soup before
this will be my first time yes are you
seeing something i just heard something
what did you hear i don't know kitchen
noises i guess i'm wondering if lemon is
going to carry the reasons for bud stock
i'm sorry
we're going to heat up some stock in the
pot behind us while katie is getting the
stock started i have some shrimp here
we're just gonna roughly chop this i'm
not gonna do it so that's super super
minced uh just because i like the chunks
in there in the wontons all right lem if
you're here
can you give us a sign
do you like
shrimp and pork wontons
so we're gonna start combining our
dumpling filling which is gonna be some
pork
okay okay no joke he's right here guys
ghost i swear to god do you see him yes
do you see him he's wearing an apron i
swear oh my god this is an app does this
so the app just represents where it's
picking up of a person
why is he wearing an apron so the
shrimp's ready to go yes i'm just going
to set this to the side we have the pork
here
the next thing we're going to add peanut
oil
we're going to do some sugar some white
pepper
corn starch
salt some shouting wine a little dash of
sesame oil now we're just going to mix
this all together i'm just using my
hands
so i am folding in the roughly chopped
shrimp i left them slightly chunky just
because in wontons when you get like a
little bite of it the shrimp juices make
it really nice and moist jasmine why
don't you show me how you like to wrap
your wonton so usually
i place it in the center
take a little bit of water thank you
absolutely i'm gonna fold this bottom
part of the wonton wrapper upwards
nice and sealed and then i'm going to
take these two corners and fold it over
like this lamb if we are folding this
correctly can you give us a sign
okay so we've turned on an app that
shows us like when voices spike and we
hear things so we can ask a question
then we'll see if anything responds
lem or any other spirit's presence
please make yourself known
the dumplings
wait
you heard that right yeah
did you guys hear that that was weird
that gave me chills right you guys
reacted at the exact same time because
there was something over here yes like
something got knocked over yes i heard
that there's nothing over there to be
knocked over
this is weird
so our wontons are done now we're going
to prepare our vegetables well julian
some carrots this was called war wonton
soup pretty much it's like an everything
wonton soup whatever you have at home
you kind of just throw things together
and you got yourself a very hearty meal
the carrots are done let's you want to
prep the broccoli now i'm just cutting
up the broccoli
i have these uh florets i'm just
chopping them a little smaller so now
we're just prepping our bok choy i just
like to peel it like this
and then give it a good wash because a
lot of bugs get stuck in between the
layers of the leaves and let's finish
with the last vegetable which is the
mushroom okay you trim those up i'm
going to start boiling water so we can
blanch our vegetables okay and cook our
noodles so i'm just removing the stems
here and then we're gonna thinly slice
them yeah stuff definitely has happened
today while we've been here
but i'm still kind of skeptical if
that's my mind like playing tricks on me
i don't know i feel like it has to be
something we're cooking food that is so
closely tied to like this restaurant's
history we're just gonna get to cooking
we're gonna blanch our mushrooms
blanch our bok choy
our broccoli
our carrots
we don't want to over blanch them we
don't want them to be soft then we're
going to boil our noodles
and for our noodles we want them to be a
little al dente as well
our wontons
we stepped away for literally one minute
and the fire is out no one touched
anything it's also not easy to bump into
this you actually really can't touch it
no yeah
maybe
the ghost doesn't want us to be making
this maybe he's like it's done we're
just going to drain them and transfer
them to our stock here
so we added our wontons into our stock
now we are going to add just careful
your money how did that happen
what just happened
that is so weird her love is on the
counter and not on her
wasn't it hooked onto yours i literally
just checked it and i didn't do that
that was weird
now that we've added our wontons into
the broth we're just going to add
literally everything we just cooked our
noodles got our carrots bok choy
broccoli and our mushrooms we're just
going to continue cooking this for about
two minutes or so i was just outside um
talking to the staff and they said that
the crew that comes to clean at night
used to clean around like 3 a.m and they
like refused to do so now because of so
many things that have happened they said
all of the
glasses on the bar have been thrown down
they said like they've tried to take the
mop away
while they're mopping
well this is done so we're going to put
it in our bowl
and then top it with some green onions
some bean sprouts and some white pepper
oh that looks so good so soupy so
comforting lemon is going to be thanking
us or whoever's going to be in the booth
so we are at lem's booth
and we have left a seat right here for
lem to join us as we dine
cheers i don't know if we want to cheers
cheers to all of the parents yeah thank
you for hosting us yeah i just felt
something weird on my leg it was like
someone pushed my leg
delicious
i feel like the wonton soup is very
comforting very homey if andy spirits
are here right now
do you give us like one final sign
are you guys doing that no i i just saw
the lights like the lights just went out
they're right there
yeah they're over here
no one was near any of the light
switches
this is really weird because they're
over there
and they're over there and no one was
standing by them this is kind of cool i
like i thought nothing was going to
happen today
and i feel like they're definitely here
i swear i have goose bumps let's go have
a quick at the bar because i want to see
like that's where most of the action has
been happening final drink at the bar
this is where some of the most
activities happen so we felt like we
should just at least have a drink here
and i feel like the feroza was known for
drinks and going to the bar and coming
here late one of the most popular drinks
was the mai tai they said so that's what
we're having to my time cheers guys
cheers our soup didn't get them here
this is gonna be our soup i think our
soup got him if there is a spirit
present
will you please send us a sign
showing us that you are
here perhaps i pick up a glass
oh god no i don't want that to shine
next to me can you imagine what those
lights went out no those lights went out
again
i missed it
the light over there went off oh i
flipped back on
so just to recap what happened
we asked for a sign for any spirits all
of
those lights went off over there that
were above the tables and then the
lights all around that like highlight
all the headshots went out and then came
back on oh my god oh my gosh
and again no one by the lights i was
very skeptical that anything was gonna
happen today i definitely think we made
some kind of communication yeah i i
think today i felt like there were
ghosts here and it was confirmed that
there are ghosts here and i also think
that food really does connect us all i
was scared before we got here and i'm
leaving scared
cheers
if you guys love halloween then you're
going to love casey's halloween special
make sure to check out martha and
snoop's very tasty halloween featuring
martha stewart snoop dogg and our very
own friend alvin it's now streaming on
peacock go watch it bye guys bye girls
bye bye bye everyone
don't come home again
[Music]
you